we all love images on the web images can
be beautiful fun and informative now the
web started life is a text-only medium
check out these early versions of
well-known websites the facebook.com/
looks pretty cool huh but the ability to
embed images was the innovation that
really made the web take off and now we
have an incredible wealth of images on
the web here's one of millions of
pictures from the Google Art Project you
can probably get closer to the picture
here then you can in the actual museum
now given the huge increasing variety of
devices and contexts for consuming web
content now we need to think again about
how we use images I'm Sam Dutton a
developer advocate at Google and I'm
Cameron Pittman a course developer at
Udacity and will be teaching you how to
use images responsively so they work
really well across a variety of devices
display sizes and connectivity scenarios
throughout this class you'll be building
a webpage design for a blog site that
uses several kinds of images and by the
end you'll be confident that you can
incorporate images responsively in your
own work let's get started yeah let's do
it